hallo leute hier ist eure sehr sehr
wütende mal wann und warum ich so wütend
bin skandiert sehen als youtuber kriegt
man öfter mal eine anfrage ob man dieses
produkt bewerben möchte oder ob man mit
dieser firma zusammenarbeiten möchte und
mittlerweile sind wir glaube ich auch so
weit dass wir sagen können ja das kann
auch ein youtube machen ohne gleich die
geldgeile geile gallo geldgeile
geldgeile die geldgeile [ __ ] zu sein
oder der geldgeile hurra kuh ist eine
männliche form von einst nur manchmal
schreibe mich auch firmen an bei denen
ich sagen
dieses produkt ist jetzt wirklich nicht
meins oder die philosophie von der firma
mag ich nicht und ich muss das nicht
haben aber das ist auch in ordnung dann
lasse ich sie weiterleben
sie lassen mich weiter leben und jeder
geht seinen weg und alle sind cool und
dann kam letztens eine anfrage von
junior 1
du kannst live streams bauens machen und
damit bares geld verdienen
oh mein gott bargeld von you know you
know
ihr möchtet also dass sich werbung für
euch machen könnt ihr haben aber eine
frage vorweg sommer habt ihr noch alle
latten am zaun und sind euch alle
erdenklichen tassen aus dem schrank
gefallen
ihr seid das allerschlimmste was es an
live stream angeboten auf der ganzen
welt gibt
ich war als auf jona unterwegs und wenn
ich nicht gerade auf super gründe shisha
rauchen typen gestoßen bin dann habe ich
mit ihren dabei zuschauen können wie sie
sich über 1000 instagram verlor freuen
aber das ist ja noch gar nicht alles ich
habe innerhalb von einer halben stunde
mein glaube an die komplette menschheit
verloren mal davon abgesehen dass sich
manche einfach beim nichtstun filmen die
kamera nebenbei her laufen lassen wären
andere mädchen also kleine mädchen
danach gefragt ob sie ihre füße zeigen
können und ob ihre oberweite wirklich so
groß ist dann habe ich noch super coole
jungs gefunden die draußen geraucht
haben oder irgendwelche mädchen klicken
die da sitzen nur darauf warten dass in
frage gestellt wird oder dass sie
endlich mal jemand sagt was sie tun
sollen
ich hatte ein wunderbares erlebnis mit
diesem jungen
man hier denn als ich zum stream
gekommen bin wollte er die ganze zeit
dass die anonyme person sich doch mal
bitte anmelden soll weil er das ja nicht
mag wenn jemand anonym zuschaut ich mein
hallo du machst im internet einen
öffentlichen stream und beschwert sich
dann darüber dass ich mal anonym
zuschaut
ich glaube manche leute checken wirklich
nicht was es bedeutet wenn man bei you
now einen stream laufen hat dass da
jeder hans und franz zuschauen kann und
dann beschwerte sich darüber dass die
anonyme person sich doch mal bitte
einloggen soll das mag ja nicht ich
mache das nicht so wenn jemand zuschaut
wie ich eine kippe nach der anderen
raucht und meine wahren helden sind
diese raren geschwister die ihre
jüngeren vor die kamera ziehen weil sie
wahrscheinlich gerade auf die aufpassen
müssen denn sicher sind mama und papa
grad nicht im haus oder genau und dann
wird schön das kleine geschwisterchen
noch damit vorgezogen weil man muss ja
auch das aufpassen aber wie soll man
gleichzeitig stream und auf dem kind
aufpassen
die eine war 13 und die andere war 9
bitte hört auf
ich werde so sauer und die kassen ihren
doch erkenne wahl die die können das
doch gar nicht entscheiden und dann
tanzen sie da vor der kamera und
verstehen doch gar nicht was es heißt
dieses team also die verstehen nicht
dass so viele leute zugucken wenn wir
das bewusst wenn ich wette die wellen zu
schlagen würde es nicht tun
tectoyou auf fick dich einfach die
seltsamste situation war wirklich diese
hier wo der opa mit zwei jungen damen da
sitzt und ich weiß gar nicht ob der das
gecheckt dass die kamera nie und nimmer
sachen gesagt wo die mädels sein lachen
mussten und die haben da bier getrunken
und es war 18 uhr und es war alles so
wie er die ich weiß nicht ganz ehrlich
vergisst nachmittags adtv denn reality
tv hat seine neue stufe erreicht und
jetzt ist es richtig reality vorerst
immer alles gescriptet by you know
kriegst du reality tv ich hoffe das ist
bald vorbei und was darf bei so einem
schönen nachmittag auf you now auch
nicht fehlen
das eine vollbusige 16 jährige ihre
adresse freigibt damit ihre fans ihr
post zuschicken können
ich war nicht meine halbe stunde auf you
know und erlebe schon so eine scheiße
nicht meine halbe stunde war ich da das
war nur ich bin von einem spiel zum
nächsten gegangen und jedes mal wird
schlimmer der berg der scheiße artig
gehäuft weil diese scheiß seite einfach
nur scheiße ist und zu guter letzt habe
ich natürlich auf you know eine billige
baby und julian kopie mit der wehr würde
er challenge und die gehen wenigstens zu
dass sie geschwister sind
das ist mein stichwort zum schluss
machen heute sorry für dieses rage video
aber ich musste das einfach mal gesagt
haben und ich bin noch nicht mal so
sauer auf die leute die die live streams
machen sondern auf you now als plattform
das you know as you now gibt und es ist
da menschen gibt die sich die taschen
damit voll machen dass kinder sich
präsentieren können und dass pädophile
neuen spielplatz haben
ganz ehrlich dass da niemand noch was
gemacht hat